well it is now facing an emergency
that's also one of the worst disasters
that mankind faced in the last centuries
so this is the most immediate thing but
as you do in this question which implies
food implies medicaments implies shelter
as you deal with these water as you deal
with that with these more immediate
questions must also think in the medium
and the long prayer a lot has a lot of
progress can be made before the
earthquake in the political front in the
security front in the even and economic
front because there was more interest of
business people so we have to now
harness all these interests and make it
come again and you see because there is
there's no way that you can separate
completely the emergency from the long
term so I sooner that the business
people come there also and start to make
their plans as if I said here in the
tourism industry garment Brazilian
Brazilian industries are very
interesting epinal is where an errand
with Brazil's can help but in order to
help haiti there we have the technology
and we have even the disposition but you
have to have the market so you have to
have receiving facilities in the US
Canada or European markets so that we
can do that as well that's just as an
example